people of the internet retro recontour
here and we are back with harry potter
and the prisoner of azkaban welcome back
thank you all so much for joining me
part one was an incredible success
and if i remember correctly i think that
we're just ready to uh end the day
uh yeah i just press z here and let's
just take a double check look through
everything here find the marauders map
so we got the marauders map
and we've got check marks all the way
around so i'm gonna go ahead and hit end
day and see what happens next
harry and ron got up bright and early in
preparation for their first defense
against the dark arts club nice however
not everyone was quite as lively that
morning
hermione
uh
we've got a fence against the dark arch
glass what's wrong with hermione
i'm on my way that's about to say dude
look at her hair
oh wow okay so we're in control of
hermione now all right
man i tell you guys it has been a crazy
week for me a crazy week
uh we had a bit of a
covet scare in our family
um nothing too crazy just
my son as you guys know regulars know
he's in school he's
in second grade
and so far
we hadn't had to quarantine any
no quarantines at all
uh they've been wearing masks at his
school and you know trying to maintain
distance as much as you can with kids
that age
and there's been a lot of people in his
school quarantine and across our school
district but
so far he hadn't uh unfortunately
monday
we got the dreaded call
the dreaded call that or actually an
email that that he would need to
quarantine so
we went ahead and got him tested
immediately and and everything was fine
he he did not
test positive but he has to get tested
again friday
and as long as everything checks out
then he should be able to go back to
school monday so
it's been a crazy week we're kind of
doing uh school at home again for this
week all right where do you want me to
go let's see let's take a look again
here
[Music]
okay defensive against the dark arts
classroom on the third floor all right
man they just need to relax like they're
panicking so much we need to get going
we really need to get going a prefect
badge last seen in the entrance hall if
found please return to this notice board
yeah i think i mentioned it in the last
time the menus in this game
nowhere near as slick as in chamber of
secrets
i mean particularly with that spot right
there like it used to be a really nice
little uh
slick menu that you were acting so
strangely since we came to hogwarts
it's through here oh wait scabbers he's
already talking about scabbers
it's through here okay so yeah let's see
all that's locked
and i don't think i'm just trying to
remind myself what all that we have so
far
yeah we've got expelliarmus which is
really more like fortego in this game
uh and let's see can we interact with
any of those
yes we can
what nobody bought beans you gotta be
kidding me dude that's one thing that is
so annoying me already every time you
try to do something
they're trying to like talk you out of
it i really hope hogwarts legacy
does not
urge you to the next checkpoint and just
kind of let you explore for a bit
that's happened several times already in
this one they're just like trying to
hurry me up can we go now
i mean for real
my goodness ron like just relax dude
can we go now i mean
and it's not like i'm exploring for 10
15 minutes i mean i just like looked the
wrong direction
and they're like
can we go now oh my goodness okay ron
will you let me just like kind of look
around the room for a bit or do you not
even want to let me do that
you kiss this like any little time yeah
oh wait i didn't mean to do that
actually
dude you can't interact with anything
all right i know a lot of you love
prisoner of azkaban i'm just gonna give
you my early thoughts and they're still
let's go
seriously
holy cow
uh what do we have here gun hilda of
gorsmore
corridor say what
say what
yeah just my early thoughts like
there's a lot of interesting ideas in
this game so far it'll be waiting for us
and i can definitely tell there are some
things they tried to add but just so
much of the charm
of chamber of secrets i feel like has
been left behind and all of these little
quirks like just the
the thing about urging you on to the
next checkpoint and the the menus
they're just not nearly as slick
so i can definitely see
this it wouldn't surprise me at all
can you get out of my way it wouldn't
surprise me at all if uh if they were
rushed in the development for this game
wouldn't surprise me at all but we're
still very early in the game obviously
it has plenty of time to uh
impress me with some other things i
don't even know if i'm going the right
way he said i need to go see
lupin on the third floor in defense
against the dark guard so we we're on
the third floor though can we be going
to defense against the dark cards yep
yep we should okay marauders map let's
pull that up we just got the marauders
map
hello
hello nothing what
why isn't anything showing up there
third floor defense against the dark
arts
[Music]
what
why is the map not showing anything
that's so weird to me
okay so it could be
oh my goodness the frames
the frames
see here
all right well maybe we weren't even
supposed to come down this corridor at
all
oh my god
i completely missed it
i completely missed it come on
here we go we made it
would you come here please oh is this
the blogger
is this going to be the bar class
already i would like you to go in there
and bring the glacier spell book
nope no bogger just just go
get this glacier spell book can you go
get that please don't worry lupin we'll
take care of it we'll handle it glacier
spellbook okay let's see it is that way
yeah that was just gonna go back
by the way guys it's hard to believe we
are already in the month of november
let me know what you guys are looking
forward to this holiday season i put up
a poll question on the channel on our
community page asking uh any big games
that you're looking forward to this year
so many people responded hogwarts legacy
i'm like guys i know i know we want the
game
but i'm talking about this year this
year hold r to target your opponent and
then cast your spell wait what do you
want me to cast just gopindo
like the most op spell ever made oh
goodness you're getting him over here
wait how do i lock onto harry
there we go
but yeah let me know what games you guys
are looking forward to picking up uh
i've started playing metroid dread
if you guys check out all the uh videos
on the channel you saw i put up a let's
play that but i have not yet gotten back
to it oh wiggle wiggle repeatedly i'm
i'm doing it repeatedly
okay finally
am i just like get all these guys i'm
really not sure what's going on here
yeah i really want to get back to
playing metroid red obviously we want to
finish up prisoner of azkaban as well
but definitely keep an eye out for those
uh other
metroid dread let's plays and then we're
certainly going to finish prisoner of
azkaban and i do eventually want to get
to uh get back to quidditch world cup i
think that one kind of grew stale a
little bit with people just because
the gameplay is pretty much the same
right and and we didn't technically beat
the game we won the hogwarts house cup
flipping cold
so flipping cold but i would like to try
and win the uh quidditch world cup as
well at some point
we'll just kind of have to play it by
ear and see how it goes what's
interesting is after
uh this game after prisoner of azkaban
we really start to
go in that downward spiral
of harry potter games because
four
i wasn't a huge fan of four
five was actually pretty solid wait are
they not gonna help her at all
i thought five was solid
six wasn't too too bad
um oh yeah we're gonna have to pull the
cauldron
but then
seven part one and two which i never
played by the way
i i've heard it is among the worst harry
potter games ever made
so
oh wait will you help me lift this
dude you actually have to ask you
actually have to press the button to get
them to come over here and help with
this oh my goodness all right here we go
though they're finally over here we're
sure this is going to work yep ron we're
sure this has only been a mechanic in
video games for
as long as i can remember
but yeah so it's going to be interesting
to see the rest of the way and then of
course the lego games
is when things really turn around a lot
of people
feel that those are actually the best
harry potter games
ever made if you if you actually look at
it across the board i'm pretty fond of
the lego games again like all the harry
potter games it's it has been a while
since i played them so
i remember them being certainly a little
simplistic but they really do seem to
capture the spirit of harry potter
and the fact that you know you can you
can free-roam around the castle quite a
bit once you get in there
all right so nothing here see i i'm
gonna explore dude when hogwarts legacy
comes out i'm just gonna be like going
around the castle
looking at every little corner to see
what i can find and that's the thing
they really have to try and make sure
they capitalize on right they have to
make sure that they
make it to where you just want to get
lost in there
where you could play for hours and not
even progress the main story because
you're having so much fun with the the
side quests and just generally exploring
the castle and and the other settings
because it's not just going to be
hogwarts castle we know that there's
going to be other places that we can
check out
but we're not to hogwarts legacy and
we're not to the bad harry potter games
yet so let's enjoy
what is one of the better harry potter
games in prisoner of azkaban here okay
so they were certainly calling attention
to that eye
oh wait dude
did i not already do a room very similar
to this
okay what do we have here let's see
oh we've got a little panel over here
it's got a little paw print on it
got a cauldron here let's see can we
pick up the cauldron or do we need to
i was just about to make a comment about
birdy bop beans like i feel like they
aren't nearly as
easy to find in this one as they are in
the other
other games
all right so we've got the little
cauldron right here as well i think
those are just for beans though
all right let's see can we hop up over
here maybe we can climb up right here
yeah there we go
i'm just so cold yep you mentioned that
i'm actually freezing as well you guys
may have noticed if you saw me moving my
hands i've got the little fingerless
gloves on right now
dude my my house
is ridiculously cold right now
but i do i do tend to run very cold
general in general my wife is the
complete opposite
so whenever it comes to how we set our
house she wins because she tells me i
could just put on more layers which is
it's true you know that is true i'll
have to stay here wait can i not jump
oh you gotta stay here
okay so you gotta remind me again
hermione how do i switch okay there we
go press b to switch to harry
gotcha now see now the marauders map is
uh
see what it's showing in here
yeah now it's actually i don't know why
it wasn't working there earlier
all right can we jump up right here
doesn't look like it so she's gonna stay
at that spot
can i if i go up here where she is can
he just like leap across
wait it said step on what does it want
me to step on up there
isn't it just the same thing that i was
kind of moving around with hermione oh
yeah it is
can you just jump right there there we
go let's go
let's go harry
nicely done
okay let's uh activate this right here
now see we got to get the reflection
from somewhere
[Music]
all right is he gonna stay there too
oh wait you know what i was hermione
and she doesn't have the map
no way okay that's interesting harry is
the only one
i feel like they probably mentioned that
in the first part
but it's been so long since we uh played
that i totally forgot that so that would
make sense if like harry is the only one
who carries it and
can read it and knows how to use it and
all right come on ron
okay really ron can't jump like harry
are you kidding me right now
what
is this for real
oh let's try this again whoa dude it's
actually for real it is actually for
real ron can not
move bloody freezing like harry can he
can't jump let's see if her money can i
don't think she can either i tried
dude that is so weird that is so weird
but fine
all right we gotta figure this out man
so
clearly we gotta use these mirrors let's
go ahead and jump over here harry
and oh we got this torch right here can
i grab the torch
oh wait remember there was something
about that about that eye over there
and harry potter
is dead
did they seriously just give me a
loading screen for falling in that hole
i don't believe it man i do not believe
it
okay all right let's go back guys come
on
let's let harry lead the way here
okay so clearly we we've got to do
something involving the wait what
it put me all the way back here
i didn't mean it because i think she hit
me by accident
all right come on take him out
dude i don't want to stop and fight
these guys can you just run by them
oh my goodness cutscene again and
everything
oh okay be more careful note to self oh
okay there was something up there that i
did not interact with last time and then
there's the eyeball again see how it
like kind of calls attention to the
eyeball
it's like what are you trying to show me
here exactly
and then you've got all these little
areas around the room where it looks
like you could light a torch
oh my goodness i still the camera how
it's reversed the horizontal is inverted
and you can't change it
so ridiculous
okay yeah we know harry can cross over
the gaps i'm not even gonna mess with
that okay wait this is the one where
i fell right
oh no i made it i made it over here last
time
and then i fell right here
okay you can't really do anything to
interact with that
all right but we've got the fire over
here i thought i fell again i thought i
fell again i'm gonna be honest with you
guys
okay wait do we just need to uh hold on
maybe it's something that we can
see can it like catch the reflection of
the flame
no
that's gonna say that'd be kind of weird
i mean i guess that would that would
sort of work but
nope nope nope let go
okay
well the other spot
see i don't remember their special
abilities they all had special abilities
right
there were like special things that each
of them could do
[Music]
i'm just so cold i wonder if harry can
jump up there
to move the camera around yeah yeah we
know all about moving the camera around
i was gonna say does it replenish the
bean it looks like it does
and let's see okay we can't go up there
so we've got this on the wall over
what here that one do
oh that gives me the reflection okay
or the beam of light i guess it's not
really a reflection
i walked right up to that earlier and i
don't think anything happened let's see
can hermione interact with that or is it
only ron i feel like wait a second i
feel like
okay this is why it's it's so bad if you
if you wait
too long between playing games
it's because i forgot what ron's special
ability was i think he might have been
the only one who who was able to do that
because i definitely walked up to it
with either harry or
hermione
but apparently
nothing happened all right so i think
we're gonna have to shine the beam into
the eyeball
uh oh wait i've gotta turn it first
okay yep we see where we need to shine
it right there
all right let's let go and then harry
you need to go back over here
dude if i fell right there i would have
been so annoyed
all right now let's grab it again and
then we're gonna turn it this way
yep perfect
or wait a second do i need to like can i
light this torch right here nope he
won't even turn it
he will not even turn it again so
all right so this right here
at the end of the day i'm just like come
on dude there was there's a torch here
all along
why couldn't i just use the torch
oh there we go nice
all right let's let go there
and then we should just be able to hop
through and
oh this is points for gryffindor let's
go dude
let's go dude
what's going on now is this just a weird
camera movement or is peeves in the
house
all right
60 total points now for gryffindor oh is
it just the pixies
cornish
pixie freshly caught cornish pixies
laugh if you will mr finnegan
let's see what you make of them
oh watch out
dude the dodging is so weird
[Music]
like i i really think if they had more
time to kind of flesh this out
it could have been more of an
interesting combat system with sort of
like counters
as it stands it's just like i don't know
it doesn't feel very uh
intuitive it's just kind of like you
spam it enough and you'll you'll hit
them
and then if you want to try and dodge
every now and then sure throw a dodge in
but
at least so far the dodging isn't really
a
necessary mechanic
all right we got those guys down right
here
oh let's go dude
why are they not gone yet
oh see that one right there i should
have dodged
oh how did that not hit him
there we go it's like a delayed reaction
okay he should be gone now all right
perfect so i did not even see what this
did right here do i need to keep hitting
it
let's kind of maneuver back here yeah
there we go
now the question is does it stay
or is it gonna roll back down on me
oh can you really not make that jump
harry
go on you should be able to use that
little rock
really you can't use that rock
that is ridiculous
all right let's go over here let's jump
up here and then it's gonna drop watch
watch it's gonna drop like when i
finally get him over here okay
go right here
oh no
wait did it drop no no it's still up
okay
so wait what did i mess up on did he
just i just completely missed the jump i
guess
[Music]
oh dude can he really not grab on to
that
why can he not grab on hey hermione over
here yeah you guys need to get in here
or can they not are they separated from
me
oh they might be separated from me
okay
i feel like
you should be able to make this jump
oh my gosh it just has to be the perfect
angle
it really had to be at the exact angle
okay we got that one we got that one
uh i think i'm gonna go ahead and blast
this one over here
oh can you not hit it
because i don't know if i can make this
jump
okay got it
oh yeah we must have hit it from
right there on the target
[Music]
all right is that as high as it'll go
yep right there it's locked in
[Music]
and
over here
perfect nice job harry
took you a little bit longer than it
should have but
hey the end of the day we made it
through
all right now do we rejoin
with the
trio nope not yet
hit this see does that raise what is
that raising oh
nice okay
so now they can get through i'm gonna
actually stay up here with harry
won't let me well let me switch to them
i was going to stay up there as harry
just in case that
there's something else i need to do up
here what the heck is this
oh this is one of these guys
[Music]
i really
can't move it
okay now we can switch to them perfect
all right so
what did he open for you guys this right
here
all right i'll let ron lead the way
and nothing here
[Music]
wait what now harry just rejoined them
all right i guess i'm making the puzzle
too hard he must not need to do anything
else back there
all right we kind of see what we need to
do here which i think we're gonna need
to
switch to harry again
there's some kind of switch over there
will that do anything
oh okay i think harry's gonna need to
stand on one
that's done something at least okay
let's let hermione stand on that one
done something at least
ron stand on there
oh we gotta move the boxes too
and then i bet ron has to be the one to
go up there and use the oh no what are
you doing harry
oh i didn't mean to switch to hermione
oh yeah
the controls what i want to do is let go
okay
and we're gonna go to the side here
and push it this way
that's done something at least all right
let go
and then let's
let's get hairy i want to see if harry
can progress there's a switch over there
because i don't think he can i think
it's only ron but then again hold up
ron can't uh jump on all these things
like harry can oh wait so now
what is this oh that's a chest
it's like what is that over there i
think we've got to get to that switch i
think you're right hermione
i just realized i totally didn't uh
check that wizard card from earlier so
let's go ahead and check it now
let's see if
it uh shows us
and highlights the new one
oh wait i forgot where to go it's the uh
folio
folio universitas
all right oh we got one classical beast
i don't think we had that one yet i
think we were all quidditch so far
the mountain troll
frequents mountainous regions very
powerful but stupid the troll will
attempt to bludgeon anyone who comes
near it and then let's just kind of
recap quickly
the quidditch ones we have here uh sippy
neodyl jocelyn wadcock
and leopoldina
smithwick first british witch to referee
a quidditch match 1829 to 1910 there you
go late
uh and then 1800s up what is this right
here we've got like
oh over there to the right it's just
showing me that i need one more to kind
of complete this little
set right here
all right very cool very cool let's go
back to the adventure
so can i hop up on here as harry
oh wait can i move this now
let's see if it
no you cannot okay so it has to stay and
they have to stay
let go and the question becomes
i got it i got it i got it i got it
you have to uh with one of them see i i
got to remember that you've got three
characters you can use here
i'm gonna be so mad though when i get up
there and harry can't even press the
button
can he not like jump on top of this
there we go
come on
oh no
i see what i'm gonna have to do though
i'm gonna have to take it to
uh one of these sides
oh man can he make that jump yep right
here see where it's a little lower
so harry has to be able to press the
button in right because
uh ron and hermione can't make the jump
they can't make the jump
so harry has to be able to do it or or
he has to be able to get them
up there somehow
okay let's go ahead and hop up here come
on harry
and then here and then here
okay perfect
and by perfect i mean absolutely
terrible
what are you doing
oh what
the controls dude they're so wonky like
there's no way that should happen over
here oops yes totally not what i meant
to do
here we go
grab on
or just just go ahead and open this
another wizard card
yeah
oh wait no what is this
what is this
some sort of scroll
what
it doesn't even tell me what it was
or is it just like part of the spell or
something that we're trying to collect
[Music]
like for real what was it
what the heck
dude it was just like some little
parchment and he's like uh yeah sure
yeah sure okay let's switch to
uh let's go ahead and stand here with
ron
and with her mining done something at
least
let's go ahead and grab
this
block right here
hermione doing all the work as usual
wrong complaining ron complaining about
being freezing while hermione is trying
to do all the work guys and get us out
of trouble
all right let's put this one done
something at least and then let's stand
right here
okay if harry cannot press this
okay he can't good
that wasn't just something special with
ron i just must have uh not gotten close
enough with harry in that last room
or or positioned him just right in front
of it
okay can i totally leave here uh looks
like i can
i don't think there's anything else to
interact with here let's go ahead and
grab this
oh goodness from these books though
yeah i know that
dude the controls are so wonky like what
i dodged
oh wait wait wait is he one that i have
to do
can i do expelliarmus on him
yes we can
there we go send it back at him
i will say i i like that the parry is is
way more forgiving in this one than
then in chamber
as i just as i just missed it
yeah there's a much wider window for
when you can hit it
why am i not speaking of hitting why am
i not hitting him
he's about to kill me
what
okay maybe i just wait
excuse me
excuse me
his health's not going down
i'm trying hermione i know you're cold
maybe i need to kind of like change the
angle or back up
[Music]
dude i did the same thing i've been
doing what in the world
why did that take forever to work
the better question why don't they just
stroke it as hagrid has has told them
maybe they have maybe he hasn't taught
them that just yet okay now that i got
rid of you now what
did i pick that up
wait what
what wait
wait
do i have to walk on this side of it
hey come over here
come on up here lend me a hand
i'm at a loss what did we do wrong guys
what did we do wrong
oh no
okay hold on there's probably a switch
in here that i missed
okay let's see nothing over here
let's see is there anything up top
because i did not go up top on that side
right there
and then we already pressed the switch
at the opposite end
uh let's see these panels
they do not do anything anymore
we've got the door here
and it's locked okay so we can't go back
dude did that is this like a glitch
did i just hit a game breaking glitch
here
no no wait
it's one of their abilities
i'm gonna forget i i need to just like
play this entire game this week
and then just post the uh
you know like spread out the posts
for when the let's plays go up
because man
completely forgot that that's ron's
secret ability
[Music]
the heck
oh
what do they call these things
okay put them on his back
oh he just ron just
actually killed him like he just
he just straight up killed him with
lupino right here
all right okay let's do this ron you got
to make it through on your own buddy
no more complaining just see if you can
help out the trio and get them through
this here
all right let's blast this right here a
couple times
or only one looks like one time
and the pixies have been set free again
and it broke fabulous
just fabulous
all right let's
i wonder if i can let's see if i can oh
you can't actually switch to hermione
while they've
grabbed hold of uh ron
[Music]
come on ron actually do something man
actually do something oh man look at
harry though there he comes flying in
just like
ron get out of my way and he won't get
hit by flopindo
dude
harry just comes flying in there with
the flapindos
knocking him down
left and right wait what i think we got
him harry
i think we're good
all right thank you buddy appreciate it
okay i know i just saw a panel
this is a different room oh no this is
the same room
wait a second
and how do we get up there
i need to get harry over there
all right so let's switch to harry so
he's the one that can make the jumps
all right then we're gonna go right here
wait why is the uh
we don't have the reflection anymore
a little beam of light
oh i just botched it
oh thank goodness i was like how far
back is this gonna put me right here
all right so that's broken and then the
pixies come out
they grab ron
he's like please hermione help oh we
have to fight them again though okay
that's kind of annoying
that is very much annoying
[Music]
at least harry's helping out like ron's
just like standing there panicking
movie ron indeed i guess
is that it
all right there we go
okay oh that's right it opened up this
right here
there we go
nice i can find the glacier spell book
all right let's go hermione you got this
hopefully we don't have to get through
any hidden passageways over here without
ron since that's like
the old weasley family uh oh man i
forgot what he called it
but it was very funny you could check
that out in part one
in our first let's play for harry potter
and the prisoner of azkaban oh dude i
actually love these puzzles
loki oh he loved these puzzles right
here
all right so that should slide there and
then we're good
assuming that you need to go this way
hop up there
oh wait though i want to get the uh
oh hermione please turn around i don't
want to use this awful
reversed camera
oh hermione can't make the jumps though
yeah see look at that she just falls off
that's so weird
just so weird
all right well
is this a switch right here
it is a switch
and then up here
dude there's two chests right there
all right two chests right there one
chest right there
okay well this is this is pretty simple
we just need to take this right here
in order to get the block to stay on it
push this right here and then we're just
going to push this one up whoops
push it up and then push it uh slide it
down to the right
[Music]
all right so now it should stay there we
go perfect
[Music]
no i don't want to push that one
oh my goodness hermione
this one
there we go
all right so all it did was
i i don't understand it just like made
the other one disappear down there
slide down into the floor i don't see
how that helps me though at least not
yet
oh dude that's problematic though now
right because
oh it's gonna slide
and it slides off
oh tricky tricky
okay so hold on here's what we got to do
if we want to try and get those chests
over there
which you may have to i don't know maybe
required
all right now we need to oh come on
the controls man they're so wonky
all right let's go with this yep we know
that's not going to stay
and then i'm going to push this all the
way back can i just lipendo them what is
that because it keeps lighting up you
guys see that
oh
that's awesome
i have to remember that
all right so now can i hop up here
there's that only harry that can do that
yes thank you
thank you hermione can actually climb
even though she can't jump
all right well
wasn't really all that worth it but
maybe this one will be
oh my gosh i just did that for six beans
i just did all that for six birdy bop
beans
oh that's how it goes sometimes okay
wait before i do that though i need to
send this one back
no i don't want you standing on it
back there
and give you a little push to go all the
way back down
perfect
all right now
no
it's not where i want you to go
oh for real okay wait hold on
all right now let's go and send you
i know it looks like i'm just like
terrible at controlling her
but the controls are actually that wonky
trust me like you think you're aiming
right at it no
no not at all all right again though
what is the point of this can i just
drop okay good we can
the only thing i can think of that would
be the point of this
huh
okay now we can get the
i see
now we can get that block to go all the
way to the edge there which i think is
where they want
because then we can climb up
and that should give us access to that
chest up there
which at this point i'm like do we even
bother with the chests
all right
climb up here there you go nice job
hermione
all right let's see what's in here we'll
check it anyway maybe it'll be something
good
good hey what's your card
i still want to know what that random
piece of parchment was
ish if anybody knows let me know in the
comments
the random bit of parchment that i
oh wait i meant to look at the uh
the wizard
god let us see here
folio universitas oh it's one of the
witches
morgan le fay
medieval
dates unknown king arthur's half-sister
dark sorceress enemy of merlin oh
interesting i'm uh
my son is absolutely loving the magic
tree house series right now
and morgan lafaye appears in those and
but she's she's not evil at least not
yet
hope she doesn't turn evil she's uh
she's pretty nice right now
but they're actually working with merlin
too so
okay let's see do we need to do anything
else there i don't think so we're free
to go this way now
and hopefully we are getting close to
the spell book
oh
something big happening
i feel like we're gonna need the full
trio for this one
yes there it is
hold on though it can't be that simple
do i just walk out there and get it
yep let's drop
oh
looks like the ice is cracking
[Music]
wait for it
got it yes
the glacier spell book
[Music]
so i wonder what the spell is actually
gonna do in game
maybe like you can make your own pillar
of uh
ice
to create a platform or something i
could see that
all right here we go i need to map
glaciers right now freezing spell
freezes water and extinguishes fire okay
that's nice
can i not equip it to b nope you cannot
equip it to b
or a so it looks like x and y
all right i'm going to keep
i'm going to keep a flupindo just
because you use it for
so dang much
oh wait what just to hold it down
oh wait
oh and then you can angle it down
this is also inverted by the way
all right hold on was i supposed to go
another way
use the glacial spell to cool fiery
opponents
oh is that actually an enemy
[Music]
why did it move
oh my goodness it is
the heck
and then flip into it
i am so confused why am i not destroying
this thing do i just need to
keep freezing it no okay it becomes
unfrozen
all right so i think we came the right
way
i really don't understand why those
torches are just randomly floating
though
unless peebs is involved or
one of the ghosts is involved
all right let's go and check out that
wizard card as well
the folio universitas
another witch
we have morgan le faye and now ignatia
wildsmith 12 27 to 13 20 the witch who
invented flu powder
there you go get a good look at her
and now we're going to try and figure
out how to get out of here now that we
have the glacier spell
it actually was kind of cool just like
being able to
freeze that whole little area around me
dude what is going on here
are they fighting
hey more gryffindor points
can i use it right there
weak
what a weak spell
did absolutely nothing
absolutely nothing to that fire right
there but that's fine that's fine
we'll deal with it
all right we already see we're gonna
need to move a block
again
see i don't think she can reach that
right there
all right well first thing let's just go
over and uh open this chest right here
great
okay what is that
what is that it's like a piece of a of a
larger
it's got to show you that somewhere here
in the menu
is it something in here the folio brew
die
salamander
salamander is a fire dwelling lizard
that feeds on flames salamanders only
live as long as the fire from which they
emerge burns wow
so the the other uh kind of ice creature
that i came across moments ago looked
like sort of like an ice salamander but
it's not showing up yet billy wig
billy wigs are particularly difficult to
catch dried billywig stings
are used as ingredients in certain
potions wait dried billywig stings
like stingers i guess
all right maybe that page up here nope
that's challenge scores
yeah i i legit have no idea what that is
so i'm curious to see if any of you know
out there
what those pages i'm collecting what
they're going toward all right what
happens if i freeze this right here does
it make oh awesome
it makes the little pillar for me
okay now the question though is
how do we get it to where we want it to
go
oh is it locked right there
it is okay so i guess we have to go wait
what
wait
oh it's like
i have no idea what the movement on that
is
none
wait wait wait
so i guess i kind of like knocked it off
that dark area in the center
but now i can't go over this right here
so we're gonna have to push it back to
the left
oh my goodness
the controls dude let me over here thank
you
okay now can i get it back on this
little sliding area
yes we can
perfect
all right i think i see what we do
oh my goodness it works so much better
when you can just like
what how does that not hit thank you
right there we go
and let's
size it up again
and size it up again
all right now we should be able to just
grab and pull
let go
and push it this way
let go
oh no
right there let go
climb up
come on hermione climb up
wait can she not climb up on here
no
harry all right we need your help
dude i know she can climb up this right
there's no way that you can't climb up
this with her
there's no way
it's just like acting weird right now
right right
oh thank you
dude this game man the controls are so
weird
so weird why you gotta be so weird
prisoner of azkaban
all right let's head up top now oh okay
at least you grabbed on instead of just
completely falling off right there all
right i feel like there was something
yeah yeah the chest is right here don't
want to leave that behind could be
another wizard card
nope just a chocolate frog
that's okay
i wonder if harry is still lower health
where i used him in that fight against
the little monster book
do they share health or is it all i
think i think it's all different
all right looks like we're gonna need
some ice right here
can i just make it out of thin air
oh my gosh you actually can
you actually can
i didn't think that was gonna work
wait did she grab the points
let me grab the points
okay
all right go ahead and drop hermione
it's all good
use the glacier spell to put out fires
should i switch to one of them you think
you know they're like help okay you
can't switch to them perfect
oh wait harry doesn't have glaciers are
you serious
hold on or maybe i just have to map it
with him
please tell me he learned it too
he did not
he did not
what the heck
okay hold on
all right come on hermione apparently
you're the only one who knows this right
now
all right we gotta extinguish the fire
and we actually just read about how you
kill these things remember
the fire from uh which they came out of
the way
all right you know what's next
oh no get out of the fire hermione
yeah that one over there we've turned
him completely green let's go for this
guy now
are you serious there's no way you could
do that with me blasting this ice right
in your face
there we go now we put him on his back
so that was what we saw earlier they
were the fire salamanders they were just
they had their flames extinguished
so extinguish the flames and then there
you go hit them with a flapindo
done
all right now where are we going
where are we going hermione
what there's just a random
a random fire right there
oh is that a cauldron cake
i believe it was
i believe it was a cauldron cake
all right let's go
come on we've got to be about done with
this right lupin
how long oh yeah this is the entrance
this is where we came in
this is where we came in can i just like
freeze you just for fun
nope can't okay fine
games like nah nah you can only use the
spell precisely where we want you to use
this spell
and this is actually one of the places i
believe
this is like a boss fight
what
oh
this is just brilliant
okay this is just weird is what it is
what the heck
i was kidding it's actually forming like
a transformers boss fight
what is this
oh my goodness
okay is there like multiple spots i can
target
yeah i know to keep out of the way but
i'm trying to freeze him for you guys
hey hold on maybe i need to like get to
get behind him
oh you know what i want to
check now though
oh i can't switch i was trying to switch
off hermione
let's just run from these
oh he closed his mouth maybe i have to
blast him
only when that's open
he's going after them now
no no no no no no no no no no
yeah i'm trying
oh goodness we gotta dodge this though
okay now
yes there we go there we go
he's mad
he's mad oh he's really mad
dude this looks like something out of uh
dark souls
remember remember the uh
there's a couple of enemies
they do have to pindo it
no
no i botched it
i botched it
uh can i get some health here please
all right so i think the strategy is
you're supposed to just run away
until
until he does the little attack
right there
i can't i'm not gonna stop right now
now i can't
then he gets really mad
let's run away
dude this is actually kind of cool i'm
not gonna lie harry move
why is it not freezing man
oh you just destroy it you don't have to
freeze it okay okay okay
i actually like like this like this is a
pretty cool fight
it's weird it makes no sense
but i'm always a sucker for a good fun
boss fight
actually i like the mechanics of it
again even though that
the the enemy itself and uh
circumstances the situation are
incredibly bizarre
but it's good it's good
go ahead and freak out again launch that
at me i don't have to freeze it i just
have to pindo it
wait what
wait what
no
[Music]
what
i'm so confused
why did that not work
by the way i cannot switch off to the
other uh one of the others if you're
wondering
if i should try that
and his health is still like we've only
technically hit him one time
i do not understand why it didn't
destroy that little uh maybe you have to
hit it a bunch of times
this time i'm just gonna spam it
what the heck dude maybe you have to
freeze it first
i'm so lost
i'm so lost
because with the first one let's think
through this again the first time we
just tried to like
try to freeze it
nothing happened he took it back
the second time i don't think i tried to
freeze it at all i think i just walked
up
hit flipindo and that was it
[Music]
he's gonna blast that at me
and it clearly like focuses on it like
it wants me to do something with that
oh the flames were extinguished did you
see that
interesting
dude look at this like this is actually
a legit boss fight he's
he's got different phases now he's got a
completely new attack with the feed
stomping right there
we gotta make sure we keep our distance
yeah i will put the fire out i'm just
gonna wait and let this
oh
he gets a little tricky now
i don't know how i'm supposed to do it
with the uh
it's like i don't know how i'm supposed
to do it with those things firing at me
there we go we got him let's go
maybe they wouldn't use that uh dodge
mechanic that we talked about earlier
it's possible
[Music]
what what's sacking me now
is that it is he gone
okay
can we please teach the others
hold on i'm gonna look at ron's
oh dude he doesn't have it either
he's got expelliarmus and he's got
fupindo
hermione though
is she the only one who has that
that is so interesting to me
like i kind of actually like that one as
a special
because she was always the best wizard
or witch rather i guess of the three
so that one actually makes sense like
that she would know a spell or be able
to master a spell before one of the
others
but it's kind of weird they all know
um
i don't know i guess expelliarmus
influpindo are fairly
fairly basic but harry did in year five
like he really focused on
spelliarmus when he was teaching
teaching dumbledore's army and then of
course the patronus charm that that's
one that he kind of like had up over
hermione
we kind of had that one over everybody
to be honest because he was just very
adept at that one gryffindor 50 points
for gryffindor
harry
can you show me how you made the
dementor back off oh i don't pretend to
be an expert at fighting the mentors
harry
[Music]
what's going on dude why are you feeling
bad harry it's potions next potions next
well that turned out better than i
thought i gotta be honest that was a
pretty fun boss fight i think we're
gonna go ahead and wrap it there if you
enjoyed this guys make sure to give it a
thumbs up before you go that's going to
help more people find the video as
always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon